inquiète avec nous dans le public est-ce
que bonne elle peut se lever merci
gonelle merci d'être avec nous bonnel
merci beaucoup ça bonsoir et merci
d'être là car et me disais tout à
l'heure que la violence france était de
plus en plus violente c'est ce dont on
parle depuis des musées c'est vrai que
la violence elle est partout et vous
vous êtes la mère denis 16 ans tuée en
juin 2019 vous êtes taxi ambulance hier
dans les côtes d'armor
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
qui est arrivé à votre fils à mon fils
était menacé de mort depuis deux mois
parce qu'il avait voulu aider son
camarade c'est une histoire c'est
compliqué
son ami avait repéré une fille qu'il a
été déjà sorti quelques temps avant il
voulait ressortir avec don qui lui avait
envoyé un texto
mais cette fille là avait un petit ami
d'accord ce petit ami l'a très mal pris
il a commencé à envoyer des menaces un
ami de mon fils et il s'est pris de peur
donc qui lui a montré les messages en
disant qu'est-ce que je peux bien faire
et mon fils a pris le relais il a pris
le téléphone il a appelé l'autre élève
pour lui dire écoute laisse tranquille
où mon ami il a compris lé palais pas
tout seul il va la laisser tranquille il
a pu rester avec mais ça a continué et
il a reçu de fortes menaces sur son
téléphone
c'est à dire des photos de revolver en
lui disant on va venir te crever on va
venir te faire la peau
on va te mettre dans un coffre de
voiture et te faire disparaître vous
n'avez pas plainte
j'ai porté plainte à la gendarmerie de
matignon qui est à côté de chez moi
est ce que vous demandez ils m'ont dit
que c'était des affaires de gamins et
des ados et que ça allait pas aller bien
plus loin je m'écris il prenait quand
même la plainte parce que mon fils ce
qu'il voulait c'était pouvoir sortir
dehors sans avoir peur j'étais apprenti
boulanger ils allaient tous les matins 5
heures du matin à pied et il avait la
peur au ventre d'aller au travail et de
remonter
tellement que ses collègues de travail
m'ont dit et je ne savais pas j'ai se
tartiner le visage de farine et de
chocolat pour remonter chez moi pour ne
pas être reconnu
incroyable et ils l'ont poursuivie alors
bonjour en 2019 en juin dans 19
j'ai emmené mon fils au cfa d'aucaleuc
parce qu'il avait s'était pas réveillé
donc je les emmenais il y aller à
reculons et le soir à la sortie des
cours
un jeune a attendu dix minutes avant la
fin des cours la frapper par derrière
il est tombé une première fois il s'est
relevé il lui a dit que c'était une
histoire de gamins et que ça allait en
rester là
y a pas besoin d'en venir aux mains
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'ils avaient
fait tout un stratagème pour tuer mon
fils il lui avait versé du chocolat dans
le casier le matin pour salir son
jogging auquel il tenait pour le mettre
en colère il est resté près d'une heure
dans une salle tout seul à être en
colère a tapé dans les casiers
parce que à la maison lem un punching
ball c'est comme ça qu'il se calme mais
la tension est descendu donc il a pris
son sac à dos pour partir et le jeune ne
voulait pas en rester là
il lui a retapé une fois dessus par
derrière à la tête en faisant une prise
de kickboxing parce que c'est un
champion de bretagne de kick boxing
mon fils est tombé il a eu deux secondes
pour se relever mais il est retombé et
là il s'est mis dessus
il l'a frappée à la tête le médecin m'a
dit que il avait joué au foot avec sa
tête qu'il l'avait tiré sur plusieurs
mètres par les cheveux parce qu'il lui a
manqué il l'a mis se recontrent le
trottoir il lui a mis quelques claques
voyant qu'il n'était il n'était plus en
vie qu'il ne bougeait plus il a essayé
peut-être et puis il s'est sauvé il a
pris sa mobylette
enfin sa petite moto et ils repassaient
devant mon fils selon les témoignages
pour sourire devant mon fils il a fait
un grand sourire et il est reparti et
j'ai appris qu'il y avait une vidéo
on n'arrive pas à mettre la main dessus
parce que c'est sûr snapshot des jeunes
qui étaient avec lui ont filmé tout ce
qui s'était passé juin 2009 24 juin 2019
devant son cm2 avec la sortie des cours
avec l âge de 16 ans et les incarcérer
aujourd'hui non il a fait de la garde à
vue il a été attrapé le soir même en
garde à vue parce qu'il y avait 22
témoins dont des professeurs d'école et
un gars fin de la garde à vue il a été
relâché parce que mon fils était dans le
coma mais pas décidé et là ils et ça a
duré deux jours
mon fils et est décédé on a débranché
parce qu'on m'a dit que il y avait trois
lésions irréversibles au niveau du
cerveau et qu'on ne pouvait plus rien
faire
mais pendant son hospitalisation il a
passé un irm et ils ont découvert annie
un anévrisme à l'arrière de la tête et
de là quand je suis passé devant la juge
la première fois avec mon avocat maître
philippe de veulent
la juge m'a annoncé que c'était
l'anévrisme qui avait tué mon fils est
pas les coups qu'il avait reçu donc ils
ont qualifié de violence ayant entraîné
une itt était de plus de huit jours
non si elle m'a dit que c'était la
qualification qui devait être donc nous
on a fait appel et demander une
contre-expertise cela contre expertise
est arrivé huit mois plus tard ça a été
en notre sens la violence est bien
responsable de la mort de mon fils ou de
la rupture mais à partie adverse a
demandé une autre expertise
parce que à l'hôpital mais j'aurais
peut-être pas dû le faire mais j'ai
pensé procès j'ai photographié monfils
sur son lit pour que l'on voit à quel
point on l'avait frappé mais comme il a
été frappé par derrière il n'a rien sur
le visage il a aucune trace et justement
ils s'en servent pour dire que comme n'y
avait pas de trace ça n'était pas assez
violent pour avoir déclenché l'anévrisme
et donc ils partent sur quelles
hypothèses qu'on veut alors là je et
aujourd'hui il est où le jeune il est
dehors il fait ses études d'apprentis
il fait sa vie tranquillement je les
croisais il tête haute
ils se promènent devant parce qu'il a il
est à 200 m de chez l'ami à mon fils qui
est toujours menacée ils se promènent
devant chez lui avec sa famille en
souriant comment comment comment
voulez-vous donc quand on entend des
histoires comme ça que la police puisse
faire son travail c'est par gaspard
candeur excusez moi je m'adresse à vous
parce que je regardais la dame parce que
là vous étiez vous étiez auprès du
président hollande la justice ça fait
des semaines et des semaines qu'on dit
il ya quand même un énorme problème
moi je n'en mets les façons ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on a pu on écoute une
histoire pareille on peut être qu'au
révolter moi je parle enfin voilà on se
dit qu'il ya un problème énorme et on
espère que vous pouvez obtenir plus mais
là aujourd'hui nous avons encore espoir
d'obtenir justice où c'est fini alors là
la seconde expertise est encore dans
notre sens enfin quelques oeufs ont
notamment mené ce celle que ils ont deux
heures qu'ils en demandent pas dans
notre sens l'année briesmalien
interrompue soit par les coups soit par
l'agression canovas a dans notre sens
mais les faits ne sont toujours pas
requalifier ces incroyables depuis le
mois de février
j'ai une question à vous poser est ce
que et parents de ce jeune homme ce
qu'on parlait de l'éducation aussi vous
vont aussi de vous contacter pour n'en
parler jamais rien ça aussi lorsque je
voudrais préciser aussi lorsque je suis
allée au commissariat de la gendarmerie
de dinan après la mort de mon fils pour
apporter les affaires parce que on ne
m'a pas réclamer les affaires de mon
fils ni le téléphone portable ni les
vêtements qu'il portait sur lui c'est
moi qui les ai trouvés à l'hôpital et
qui les ai apporté à l'agenda et on m'a
dit il n'est pas nécessaire de prendre
un avocat
alors que la partie adverse avait déjà
pris un avocat